this jackets a game-changer can you tell
me about this jacket well my beautiful
stylist ashley weston styled me time
wearing Givenchy so this is a Javon she
get up let me tell you something I've
seen I've been in the Givenchy store
before I didn't see this jacket I didn't
see it they say before Ladd hold on
does Will Smith know now that you are
Aladdin yes I think so
because at first he did not really know
who you were didn't know he didn't
you're right first time I met him I was
really I grew up watching his films man
so I was really nervous and I forgot to
introduce myself and Guy Ritchie was
there so I thought he was gonna help
break the ice you know but he didn't so
I had to backtrack a little bit and I
went back and introduced myself a guy
left you hanging you were like you're
like I guy did leave me hanging for sir
I've I've brought that up several times
I think you wanted to see how I would
handle the situation you know to
pleasure in it
yeah I'm sure did this carpet is
ridiculous there are big carpets with
you've taken basically the whole street
and that rarely happens on this
yeah man listen two years ago I moved to
Los Angeles I was living in a closet
with my friend Elmo who's here actually
somewhere and I never thought I'd you
know get to do this so quickly after
moving here so it's been a blessing I'm
blessed
wait a minute you're living in a closet
how's it what's it like living in a
closet you just you spend a lot less
time in your room basically because
there's not much of it so I spent a lot
of time in the kitchen cooking and in
the living room did you did you
participate in crosswalk karaoke with
with James Corden I did I wasn't it was
so much fun it was so much James is like
a really nice guy yeah he's such a nice
guy but sometimes you see him on the
crosswalk musicals and you're like oh
he's not very nice but he's such a nice
dude last thing did will bring out any
of those 80s dance moves did he try to
hit those because he loves those 80s
dance moves all the time you'll see them
you'll see them in this oh yeah get
ready get ready
great meeting you congratulations thank
you congratulations
[Music]